I will share with you at least some
kind of historical information.
So in the middle ages in Europe there were these
people called hermits. The most well known type of
hermits were ones that lived in secluded places,
like the deep woods, or islands, or mountains,
or marshes, etc. Being a hermit and living a
life of seclusion, piety, and frugality was
seen in medieval christianity as a legitimate path
towards salvation. Hermits were also often seen as
wise and many people would try to seek them out
for guidance in religious matters. However, there
was another very common type of hermit, which
by the time of the 14th century became the most
common type of hermit, and that is a quote “public
works hermit”. A public works hermit was a hermit
that was appointed by either a city or a church
or sometimes even a wealthy individual to patrol
and maintain public infrastructure like bridges,
roads, lighthouses, etc. By definition all these
things were outside of population centres and,
therefore, hermits seemed like the perfect kind
of people to maintain them, even if the job of
maintaining them meant that they did come into
contact with people sometimes, which kind of
went against the whole idea of being a hermit,
but there where profits to be made so to many
people it did not matter. To give you an example,
highway and bridge hermits could exact tolls. The
initial point of these tolls and payments was to
cover the costs of maintaining the bridges and
roads, hence the job was still one of none-profit
and frugality. However, over time the hermits
and or the people/institutions that appointed
them to these positions started to exact higher
payments than was needed for the maintenance
and so made a profit which could sometimes be
fairly high. This is probably why the practice
of public works hermits became so popular in the
late middle ages over being stuck on a mountain.
So, that’s a quick medieval story about
hermits and their occupations. Anyways,
high to late medieval guilds video coming
at some point early next year hopefully.